[Applause]
eight days after breaking the world
record carsten farhom won again in the
400 meter hurdles
this time setting a new meeting record
in monaco the norwegian all set for a
tokyo showdown with america's ride
benjamin
who is also unbeaten this year no shock
there but there was an upset in the
men's 100 meters
gold medal favorite trayvon brommell was
beaten for the first time this season
upstaged by fellow american ronnie baker
jamaican legend shelly and fraser price
went in the women's 200 meters
but could only manage third with
bahamian shaunae miller weibo
powering through to take the win by the
smallest of margins
the men's 800 featured most of the
olympic favorites
and it resulted in four of the five
fastest times in the world this year
botswana's nigel amos coming out on top
in this one
and in the women's race the podium
finishers all ran personal bests
with britain's laura muir taking her
first diamond league win at this
distance
since 2018. over the 1500
the night belonged to kenya world
champion timothy chariot took the win in
a very quick men's race
which produced the six fastest times of
the year
and it was faith kip yaegon who took the
women's race
also in a world-leading time and a new
kenyan record
in the field events the czech republic's
two-time olympic champion barbara
spotakova won the women's javelin
an american katie najat came out on top
in the women's pole vault
clearing a height of 4.9 metres
the athletes were cheered on by 8 000
spectators in monaco
but things will be a lot quieter in two
weeks time at the olympics
with fans banned from all tokyo venues
david stokes
al jazeera